you know what a trailer makes the movie
look cool and intriguing then you watch
the movie that's boring your [ __ ] don't
you hate that I hate that I can't stand
it not that I has anything to do with
this movie I mean that yeah it totally
does oh my god this movie so the gunman
stars Sean Penn who's in really awesome
shape holy [ __ ] there are a few times in
this movie I'm like that dudes over 50
years old
what's up with these over 50 year olds
kicking ass just makes me I need to work
out that's what I learned Sean Penn
plays a gunman he blows this guy away he
has to disappear for like eight years
since someone's trying to kill him he's
like it must be about that one job I did
I gotta find out who's doing it kind of
it's kind of the gist this trailer made
it look like he goes to Javier Bardem
and Javier Bardem is a badass like he
was in James Bond and he's like I know
you're trying to kill me and I kept
these notes and these recordings I'm
gonna smear it all over the Internet and
Javier Bardem in Bane's voice was like
burger you're like this is gonna be
awesome it's gonna be Sean Penn vs.
Javier Bardem its dad two hitmen
badasses going at each other yeah first
of all Javier Bardem in this movie I was
like why is he in this movie he's been
played by anyone he doesn't need this
movie the only reason I can think he's
in this movie because someone's like hey
you want to make a lot of money for ten
minutes of screen time and he was like
sure but he does himself such a
disservice by playing this cartoon he's
a complete cartoonist movies ultimately
the boyfriend of Sean Penn's
ex-girlfriend who's like this alcoholic
dickbags Sean Penn's wanting to
reconnect with his girlfriend and Javier
Bardem is all jealous and you're like
this is not the hit men versus hitmen
story I was from his guys where is it
now this movie goes on and on and on and
it just gets more and more boring I
checked my watch like 58 times in his
movies see this is directed by the guy
who directed the first taken movie he
didn't direct the other taken movies but
after seeing this movie I would not have
known the difference if I was told that
he did direct the other taken movies
time to point out some positives because
I'm feeling pessimistic at this point
Sean Penn was good in the movie The
Dude's a great actor we know that and
the fact this movie sucks ass not like
he's gonna go anywhere you'll have
another shot after this movie and he
kicked ass in this movie and Han combat
could he shoot anything and kill it to
save his ass no neither could anyone
else in this room everyone's like a
bunch of blind people just shooting
bullets and there were some cool intense
action ish scenes in the movie there's
this really cool home invasion shootout
happens that was pretty intense there
are a couple other scenes - we were like
oh it's kind of getting into today
you're like okay back to the drag for
another half an hour and that's the
thing it's like this movie shows
glimpses I feel like you can get a ghost
hunter and record the audio to this
movie if you turn up the audio you'll
hear an EVP of the actual movie within
this shitty movie going somewhere and
because I could see glimpses of a good
movie in this movie in a couple of
scenes that actually were pretty intense
ish I'm not gonna dog [ __ ] this movie I
almost I wanted to I can't do it just
for the sake of entertainment I will
certainly say you're not gonna remember
the gunman in t-minus 10 minutes so yeah
it looks like it's a pretty dry weekend
all right so what is your favorite
hitman movie of all time
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]